[Music]
here's a list of the major factors which
prove the plastic has an important place
in our daily lives however what do we do
after using the plastic articles after
we realized that they're no longer of
any use to us we throw them away right
but have you ever wondered what happens
after that
what is the journey of the plastic once
it enters the garbage bin you may wonder
why is it so important to know about
plastic which is waste after it's thrown
away just think for a moment plastic is
a type of solid waste that means it will
occupy space when we throw it away
and can be a fourth the consumption of
space by waste materials at this point
of growing population absolutely not
that makes us find an alternative to
just dumping off the plastic let us
think about what can be done with the
plastic after we throw it away one
option is that we can burn it what will
that result in by burning plastics we
could effectively get rid of them this
will make sure that no space will be
occupied right wait
just think for a moment is it really
advisable to burn plastic we know the
fact that plastic just melts on heating
it does not completely turn into ashes
what remains behind is simply an
unusable form of molten plastic and is
there any other ill effect yes
burning plastics leads to release of
various harmful fumes the chemicals
released can cause severe health issues
in humans as well as other living
organisms so that means the option of
burning of plastics is completely ruled
out from our list
what other option can we think of maybe
we can try burying the plastic in soil
can this be a good option maybe yes
because that would not lead to the
release of harmful fumes and neither
will it occupy space so can we bury all
the waste plastic that gets generated
wait a second will the microbes in the
soil get affected if we
plastic in their hopes yes the stress
given to the naturally living organisms
in the soil by plastics is quite
significant but why do they get stressed
let me explain
we know that when organic matter gets
into the soil the microbes present will
degrade it this is called the
decomposition reaction but the reaction
is possible only when we have organic
matter and as far as we know plastics
are nowhere close to being organic does
their inorganic nature makes them unfit
for decomposition how do we address such
substances scientifically well those
which can be degraded by the
microorganisms are called biodegradable
parez materials like plastics which
cannot be degraded are called non
biodegradable does it is the non
biodegradable nature of plastics that do
not make them fit for burial if we still
bury them then they will only occupy
space in the soil and it will also lead
to soil pollution and what's worse is
that they will harm the natural microbes
in the soil so the option of burying
plastics also gets ruled out so we
cannot burn them or bury them what
option are we left with then what can be
done with the plastic waste generated
well the simplest most convenient and
environmentally friendly option is
recycling
yes plastic has the property to melt
when heated and the molten plastic can
be further molded into different forms
right thus the plastic waste can be
recycled to form newer useful items so
can we say we are sorted with the
plastic waste actually not shouldn't the
best option be to not generate plastic
waste in the first place don't we have a
substitute for the smaller plastic items
that we use daily
for instance the bags that we use for
shopping in markets the plastic ones can
be replaced with jute or any such
natural material this will help unless
the generation of plastic waste it is
our responsibility to keep the
environment clean and safe for other
GaN isms as well and is there a better
solution to this yes we can keep in mind
the four R's and what are the four R's
by the way it simply stands for reduce
reuse recycle and recover isn't this
principle self-explanatory of course yes
it says that we should reduce the use of
plastics in the first place if we use it
then we should use it repeatedly that is
it has to be reused once it turns
useless
we should recycle it that means we
should convert it into a similar or a
different product which is useful and
what does recover me
there are many materials which are
complex in nature these cannot be
directly recycled so we opt for
recovering the energy stored in them in
such cases we process the materials in
various stages to get the energy stored
inside them following such rules can
help us keep the environment healthy we
must not forget that a beautiful planet
is shared by many other living organisms
- keeping the environment clean for
ourselves as well as for other organisms
is one of our most important
responsibilities
you